nous sommes ici sur un terrain
d'entraînement avec des militaires
Ukrainiens qui apprennent à manier le
fanisher un drone d'attaque 100% local
créé en 2016 il a été repensé dans
l'urgence après l'agression russe de
février 2022 ici pas besoin d'attendre
les livraisons d'armes occidentales
l'Ukraine passe à l'offensive
c'est le drone le plus silencieux à 400
mètres d'altitude c'est impossible de le
distinguer à l'oreille et même par une
nuit sans vent c'est très très difficile
de le repérer c'est aussi le drone le
plus rapide du crâne car il vole à une
vitesse de 55 mètres par seconde soit
presque 200 km/h
est le drone le plus rapide sur le
terrain des opérations ukrainiennes
cette vitesse combinée à la distance
qu'il peut parcourir et sa discrétion en
fond l'instrument de prédilection de
l'armée ukrainienne pour des frappes
ciblées sur l'agresseur il est capable
de transporter une charge explosive
allant jusqu'à 2,5 kg
et de revenir sur sa base sans être
repéré autrement dit il peut atteindre
des cibles en territoire occupés en
minimisant le risque létal pour les
troubles ukrainiennes
nous avons mis en place un système de
communication sécurisée l'objectif est
de protéger non seulement l'appareil
mais aussi nos opérateurs nous
développons également divers mécanismes
qui permettent de travailler en mode
furtif c'est à dire que si nécessaire le
drone peut rester indétectable
dans la bataille des airs qui se joue en
Ukraine les drones ont une place
essentielle que Kiev veut développer
pour leur une centaine de Punisher sont
déjà déployés le long de la ligne de
front à l'heure où l'Ukraine attend
toujours le feu vert des occidentaux
pour les livraisons d'avions de combat